Japanese prime minister fumio kishida's
decision to hold a state funeral for
former leader Shinzo Abe has led to
opposition and protests Abe Japan's
longest-serving prime minister was
assassinated in July and will be given a
rare State funeral next week critics say
the decision has no legal basis and was
taken by keshuda for political reasons
protests against the state funeral
further intensified after Abe and the
ruling parties links to a controversial
South korea-based Church became known
here's more on what's become a growing
political headache for the kishida
government
this is where a Japanese man set himself
on fire in Tokyo last week he told
police he tried to kill himself in
protest against the plan's State funeral
for former prime minister Shinzo Abe
Abe's funeral has become a flash point
for public anger over political Scandal
and opposition to Abe's successor from
the same party current prime minister
fumio kashida
I think Abe was a terrible politician
and prime minister kishida said he would
listen to the opinions of Japanese
people but he is ignoring opinion polls
that show more than half of the public
is against the state funeral
's assassination in July triggered a
series of Revelations about the current
ruling liberal Democratic party's links
to the unification Church a religious
movement regarded by some as a cult
whose members are often known as Moonies
I was so shocked to find out how deeply
the unification church has been involved
in Japanese politics
this is very dangerous
I think we should not allow this to be
happening
when Abe resigned two years ago he was
an unpopular after a series of scandals
but it was his close association with
the church that was the alleged motive
for his murder
his killer says his own mother had been
defrauded by the unification Church
leaving their family destitute Abe's
killing through a spotlight on the
church's deep connection to Japan's
ruling party the ldp
prime minister kashida apologized and
promised to sever his party's links to
the church but the Fallout for the ldp
his government and him personally has
been hugely damaging
now let's get more on this from Jeff
Kingston he's a professor of history at
Temple University in Tokyo and joins me
now from the professor Kingston how
widespread is the anger over this state
funeral I mean one person appears to
have set himself on fire over it
so I think it is emblematic uh
widespread uh anger about the decision
by prime minister kishida to hold a
state funeral for former prime minister
Abe
and clearly people are not persuaded by
the reasons kishida has given
and right now about uh twice as many
Japanese are opposed to the state
funeral than are for it so this two to
one ratio in opposition has translated
into a Plunge in kishida's support
ratings so I think you know he never
ever anticipated such a strong backlash
you know in the week after Abe's brutal
assassination and there have been a lot
of positive fawning media coverage you
know the public you know more or less
two to one were in favor so that is
flip-flop sense then just about prime
minister fumio kishida all this
opposition is growing to the state
funeral why does he continue to stand by
the decision to have one
well it's already been decided so uh it
would be a real loss of face to stand
down and say you know I really
miscalculated this I thought this was
going to be politically beneficial to me
I was going to Curry favor with the
hardliners in the ldp aligned with Abe
and this would sort of be an opportunity
for the ldp to bask in the reflected
glory of the longest serving prime
minister ever in Japan uh Shinzo Abe but
what this underscores is that when Abe
resigned two years ago he was deeply
unpopular and there was a Cascade of
scandals and this uh led to an erosion
of trust in him and so his political
Legacy uh is definitely questioned uh
among the Japanese so you are
essentially saying that there is a
situation in which prime minister fumio
kishida could actually damage his own
party by sticking to this decision
well I mean they've invited all the
dignitaries there's no you know turning
back you know once he announced the
decision that was it you know and there
was no reset button
um but the problem is he didn't
anticipate the media Revelations about
the extensive and deep ties of the
Moonies with the ruling ldp so there's
been a constant drum beat of Revelations
about how close and systematic those
ties are and this is certainly uh
reflected badly on kishida and the ldp
so he tried to hit the reset button by
reshuffling his cabinet but it turns out
that most of the people he brought in
also were implicated I did want to sort
of come back to the unification chart
because it keeps coming up in all
explanations and you've also mentioned
it a number of times what is it about
the unification charge and its dies will
lead with the ldp what is the in
political influence it wheels and why is
it so unpopular
well Abe's grandfather uh was the one
that sort of facilitated the entry of
the unification Church into Japan back
in the late 60s he was close to the
river Moon and so you know these family
dynastic ties have reflected badly on
Abe and when people think of the Moonies
they think of coerced donations from
members and mass weddings and so in
general in Japan uh the Moonies do not
have a very positive image and it came
as a huge surprise that an organization
that many people regard as a cult has
such strong ties in the quarters of
power
and so people are wondering like what's
going on how could this be so I think
that there's already distrust of Abe and
now his legacy is toxic because of the
dynastic ties with the Moonies and
public perceptions that the Moonies are
like a cult and there have been more
than 30 000 official complaints by
former members of the unification church
that they've been defrauded for a total
of something like 800 million dollars so
people are paying attention and really
this has really hit kishida badly
we'll have to leave it there but thanks
so much for that detailed analysis
Professor Jeff Kingston from Temple
University in Tokyo